the toll for Alzheimer's is growing in
this country more than five million
people suffer from the disease with
Americans living longer that number is
expected to nearly triple to 14 million
by 2050 it is already the sixth leading
cause of death in the nation
on last night 60 minutes our dr. Jon
LaPook shared the personal story of
Alzheimer's impact on one couple he's
followed the devastating affects over
the course of a decade John good morning
good morning Nora
none of us including me as a doctor can
truly appreciate the struggle of a
person with Alzheimer's without living
it ourselves but Mike and Carol Daly
gave us an extraordinary gift allowing
us inside their home for an intimate
look at this cruel disease we visited
them seven times over 10 years and
witnessed firsthand the brutal toll on
both Carol and Mike when we first met
Carol and Mike in 2008 Carol was active
conversational and determined to make
the best of her failing memory how old
do you now 65 65 no I think right yeah
almost three years later when we went
back to visit Carol had no idea how old
she was 80 no I don't know you're
actually 67 67 67 now Mike a former new
york city cop had to apply her makeup
and dress her but he told us this was
his chance to repay all that carol had
done for him she had a job she cleaned
house she did the wash she made the beds
and she put up with me so what what all
that's changed for us is the rolls what
would you say the toll has been of this
long journey on you I'm dying I really
took a hit the stress don't add a heart
attack to begin with
so changed just since the last time I
saw her and her pulse is strongest can
be irregular I'm feeling it right now so
her heart seems strong but she has so
deteriorated dr. Jon LaPook joins us it
was just incredible to watch this and
I'm so glad that they let you share this
their story can you imagine the
generosity to let us into their homes
yeah and I think we all learned
something from and especially Mike you
know this former cop to talk about him
feeling like he's dying and the anxiety
faces this disease place is such a
burden on caregivers too
yeah and I think that's the big message
for everybody and certainly for me I've
had Alzheimer patients with Alzheimer's
persons with Alzheimer's sit across from
the desk familiy and they come back it's
but that's different than me being in
the home and over the years you see Mike
you know it was so sweet the way he's
combing her hair and putting them makeup
on her and making the beds and says I
can handle this you know I'm not gonna
put her in a nursing home but it turns
out you can't do it alone and I think
that is such a huge message here for
people 13 years is that a typical it
isn't John I mean I spoke to her her
neurologist doctor did Gayatri Devi who
was amazing following her and actually
almost becoming like a friend to them
over the years she said it's really an
early onset Alzheimer's she got the
symptoms probably in her late 50s and 95
percent of people with Alzheimer's
develop symptoms after 65 so this was
longer she's headed for more than a
decade as symptoms probably very closer
to 1517 years it's it's there's a
spectrum the the Alzheimer's Association
will say average survival is four to
eight years but there was a big spectrum
it can go to 20 years and there's lots
of different forms of them I think a lot
of people watching it we're looking at
that couple saying that's my biggest
fear right there especially when you
know that there's no cure there's no
drug do you see anything that's
promising in the research I do I mean I
am an optimist I know there's no cure
but one of the big discoveries has been
that the pathologic changes inside the
brain
start 10 20 30 or more years before the
symptoms so what we've been doing right
now with the medicine medicines we're
giving is maybe the equivalent of giving
somebody lipitor after they've had five
heart attacks and they're in heart
failure it's way too late so a lot of
work is going into trying to diagnose
people early before they have symptoms
maybe those medicines that aren't
working now would work then and then
there are some new medicines it's not
Alzheimer's preventable or dementia
preventable
well dementia people get confused
between dementia also so dementia is the
big label and then under that the most
common cause is Alzheimer's but that
about a third of dementia has a
component of vascular dementia meaning
tiny little blood vessels that sort of
you have a little stroke here a little
stroke there the brain tissue gets
knocked off you may not have any
physical symptoms but it diminishes your
ability to think we say what's good for
the heart is good for the head so if
people out there want to do something
now you should lobe make sure your blood
pressure is okay that your weights right
your lipids are good you're exercising
you're eating right you're the correct
weight and then social interaction is so
important that's really important it's
so rare John that you get that you or
anybody gets to follow anybody for 10
years so I'm curious about what you
learned from this particular couple of
you mentioned this is not the first time
that you've dealt with people that have
Alzheimer's what did you learn from them
you know it really wasn't an emotional
and gut-wrenching journey for me because
I'm sitting there with them and you have
the journalist and you have the
physician and you have the person and
sometimes there's some friction there
but my mantra is that the the
Hippocratic oath always Trump's the
Nielsen ratings so when you have these
moments and you saw it in the piece
which was I'm sitting there in January
when I went back with 60 minutes and he
said you know I got so bad a few months
ago I thought of putting a gun to my
head yeah and that really not the not
the air out of me and when we went off
camera now I'm clicking into doctor mode
and I had to really make sure that he
wasn't suicidal he said he was and I
made sure his doctor knew about that but
that's you know that there's this kind
of overlap between these different hats
that I wear actually he gave new meaning
to for better or worse so I know
or was it right there dr. Jon LaPook
thank you so much you